shihri lorsqu'il fallait pas louper
alors depuis ce week end eric
dupond-moretti justement le ministre de
la justice le garde des sceaux ce qui
garde des sceaux de partout partout de
jeter un seau même à la plaque n'a
jamais été critiqué pour être apparu sur
une photo en train de coller une affiche
avec une montre et des boutons de
manchette de luxe alors ça regardez la
montre la bombe qu'il portait ce jour là
était visiblement une brigue
je connais un au revoir c'est connu un
breguet marie délégués et par les
conditions je peux pas de briguer alors
quand on m'a pas donné leur attaque aux
dépens des alouettes eux la donne et je
peux pas de leur ai demandé alors comme
tout le monde a cru que c'était une
rolex c'est une breguet ces classes
c'est pas rien oui alors visiblement ça
coûterait un peu plus de 10000 euros
ah oui alors ça fait ça c'est une
polémique
est ce que vous trouvez que la polémique
autour de la montre de eric dupond
moretti est compréhensible et regardez
il s'est d'ailleurs expliqué il a une
réaction là dessus hier soir sur bfmtv
regarde il ya un arbitre des élégances
qui est sorti de sa réserve pour
critiquer le fait que j'étais monté voir
les électeurs du pas de calais et
qu'avec les jeunes quand on a collé les
affiches je portais une montre et des
boutons de manchette
mais d'abord je vais préciser que je
n'ai jamais piqué de montre un membre du
front national et à personne d'ailleurs
et que moi j'ai estimé que c'était la
moindre des choses que d'essayer de me
présenter correctement en fonction des
moyens qui sont les miens devant mes
électeurs sinon ce truc là vous
comprenez c'est du caniveau
moi j'ai bossé toute ma vie je vous le
dis je suis mais ulcéré par ces méthodes
c'est ça le front national le fonds
national des masques et c'est ça voyez
vous alors moi je vais vous dire
franchement c'est une honte
cessez donc oui on est dans un pays des
grilles eric dupond moretti avant d'être
ministre il était avocat c'est un très
grand avocat il a travaillé très dur
pour pour avoir séduit ça veut dire quoi
ce faire il faut interdire tous les
produits de luxe que personne dans
n'avoir regardé aux états unis donald
trump l'ancien président il était
milliardaire ça choquait personne là il
a une montre et tout le monde s'offusque
cc oui c'est un peu plus subtil que ça
alors moi je trouve qu évidemment la
polémique est ridicule
en fait on s'offusque de ça parce qu'en
fait il est il en train de coller une
affiche on sait très bien que cette
image est prétexte quand tu collent des
affiches moi ça m'est déjà arrivé par
exemple
mais quand tu connais les affiches tout
simplement tu dois mettre des gants
parce que là ça colle et tu peux pas
garder les mains comme ça à nu donc en
fait c'est juste une image de nous aider
sa fille jouait pour mon b d e
quand j'ai tourné avec on est rodé de
quoi aussi j'ai dû en coller une affiche
montiel connard oui
après oui évidemment c'est assez
pathétique ce qui va être en tomber en
survêt avec une swatch combat mais on va
croire qu'il est plus ou moins propres
dans le vi et on se met dans les images
valent en un seul après dans un instant
on aura la ville garde est ce qu'on va
tous avoir envie de 2,2 et chérir mentir
mais on va la voir c'est normal il est
là il est payé ma domaine sur la vie il
va encore nous emmerder bon c'est pas
grave
wiki kelly là comme un politique et le
font tous donc moi je lui en veux pas
j'ai compris qu'il lui faisait tous ils
font tous au moment de faire des trucs
ça c'est pas un souci après le fait
qu'il ait cette montre là ce monsieur a
un certain âge et à une ville à une
carrière je veux dire on pose un des
plus grands avocats très moche et
méchant
justement ce serait hypocrite de les
acteurs voile et le débat mais pour moi
c'était une petite plaque
j'aurais dit voilà je suis très bavarde
et oui mais là exactement et là on a
bien compris que la campagne avait
démarré c'est vrai vu des bonnes ventes
franchement si le niveau des bouts de
viande c'est celui ci c'est ça le global
non mais c'est vrai journalisme ni
monsieur t'écouter cissé seul niveau du
débat je prends mes clics avec l'article
c'est à désespérer si la campagne
électorale va se positionner sur ce
genre de sujets sont franchement la
politique mérite mieux on marche sur la
tête
combien je te le dit le porte parole du
gouvernement a fait un autodidacte c'est
un fils d'ouvrier alors s'il vous plaît
et pas d' insulte ici c'est démerder
tout seul toute sa vie sa fille
d'ouvrier et c'est une belle
reconnaissance et s'achète ce qu'il veut
c'est le plus grand avocat de france
sans doute évidemment qu'il est les
missiles en vue du top 5 oui ah oui
franchement voilà il a plus rien à faire
d'autre
c'est vrai qu'on va pas se mentir et
brillant un très grand avocat gaza
où il a une carrière de fou le gardien
aurait pu avoir lieu comme montre
surtout je vais vous dire j'ai touché
mon travail va mieux j'ai tout ces
montres en pâtir et le recensement de
toutes ces mondes vous voulez voir bah
oui oui c'est vrai j'ai tout de suite
allé chez lui comme vous à regarder
bassila une attaque philippe
chronographe calendrier ou là on a revu
toutes ces fautes et il a une rolex
oyster perpétuelle voilà ils adorent les
montres et la droite gère le mentionner
le nom de marque kiwi une fp journée
chronomètre souverain je croyais que
c'était un journal bien tout ça mais
même politique qui porte des montants de
prêts mais eric dupond moretti c'est un
immense regarder les appareils sont
qu'il s'attache t dmb c'est les cas
c'est pas la bête il verbe et les achète
pardonnez-moi fait du bien d'avoir faire
il disparaît et les gens quête des gens
qu'on laisse sur le carreau qui sont au
chômage
cd les horlogers cet homme les ciseaux
précisément beaucoup cédé franchement
c'est un travail oui mais il ya des mecs
qui sont fans de monde c'est les montois
l'a pas les révéler mais elle aborde
également trois moi j'adore big ben
voilà
passé la porte et je
c'est d'abord une immense faute
politique politique celle ci c'est le
parler comme ça on va savoir mais c'est
surtout une immense faute morale impasse
présenter aux élections régionales dans
la somme vouloir conquérir un électorat
populaire et s'afficher ostensiblement
comme une provocation avec les grands
avec une huître que les gens que les
travailleurs voilà servis que les
travail jour et a demandé au christ et à
l'hypocrisie
cela fait 40 ans qui vit dans
l'hypocrisie que lé valab médailles que
les travailleurs de la somme ne pourront
jamais ce pays en une vie nami mais
c'est que possible de faire ça c'est dur
applications jc issues d'un là vous êtes
une dette
c'est pas moi qui ai créé la polémique
sont les électeurs c'est bon c'est pas
bien mais c'est vrai que marine le pen
est une fille d'ouvrier sais c'est bien
que ça n'a rien à voir
très très modeste voyons tous les deux
c'est un octogone 6 et dupond moretti
ils sont tous les deux en combat et je
trouve que c'est absolument absurde de
penser que tout simplement parce que tu
es modeste était ouvrier tu va détester
quelqu'un qui a une très belle montée
des eaux était vraiment mais méprisant
ça veut dire que tu auras du mal à août
et bien sûr que si tu m'aimes bien foutu
mais faillible et jean ferrat qui parler
tu parle aux gens à leur hauteur mais
ils n'ont pas envie de sa méprise et
jean louis et puis gilles si lui n'a pas
le droit de porter une montre de luxe
qui a loix qui a le droit qui est
maintenant une chanson aussi opportune
et voilà et pour qui ils vont y faire
naître aimablement j'ai bien le droit de
vote derrière mais vous avez le droit
sert guillaume pas quand vous collait
des affiches pour une élection c'est une
hérésie de faire ça c'est une raison qui
préfère qu'ils l'enlèvent comme un
hypocrite si cris je vais faire école
pad affiche surtout qui colore joggi
pour s'équiper régime c'est quelqu'un
qui a très bien gagner sa vie pendant
des années il aurait été hypocrite de
leurs malles de cauet foule donc c'est
vraiment unique que des conneries
l'autonomie riche du gouvernement mais
c'est harry n'est pas
pensez-y
[Applaudissements]
oui à 21%
non à 70,2 sans merci les
téléspectateurs mais vous vous mettez à
ce que non mais 21 voilà il peut y en
avoir qui peuvent le penser voilà mais
quand même la majorité
oui mais c'est des arguments gilbert
dead vous êtes d'une démagogie reglèment
quand même c'est que genève s'il change
jugé mme répit la wii vous songez jamais
gilbert 21% dégoûté